(Transcribed by TurboScribe.ai. Go Unlimited to remove this message.) Добре, загалом я бачу, що так, у нас
перша команда, тому почнемо стендап.
Загалом це наш останній стендап з цього курсу.
І тоді почнемо з того, які у вас
поки що прогрес по проекту.
Давайте я розпочну з приводу бази даних, а
потім Віталія продемонструє, що ми там ще зробимо.
Добре.
Кажіть, вам видно чи ні?
Так.
Ну, додав, розібрався з формою, чому не працювало,
не відсилалося.
Так, це треба було просто дописати нейм, надавати
інпут нейми, юзерний пасворд.
І трошечки тут переписати трішки логіку, але це
для удобства більше, щоб воно нормально збирало дані.
І якщо зараз запущу сервер.
Ну, зараз.
І зробив також тут, зараз все зразу продемонструю,
щоб потім.
Ось, і логін форма, логіка, щоб ми бачили
реалізацію логіну.
Якщо користувач є, воно робить пошук по базі,
перевіряє за юзер неймом.
Якщо збігаються, то пише, що користувач залогінився, якщо
ні, то помилка.
Ось така кнопка, вибираємо там, наприклад, реєстрацію.
А це буде, наприклад, Станіслав.
Мене, зараз зарані зайду на Монго.
Мене там просто є один аккаунт, мій там
Стас наче написано.
Ну ось, тут один
юзер є, ось він.
Це Стас, а ми, наприклад, зробимо там Станіслав.
Дамо там пароль якийсь та там...
Ну можна другу там пошту дати.
Ось користувач зареєстрований.
Переходимо в Монго і у нас з'являється
цей користувач.
Ось Станіслав, об'єкт.
І якщо ми зайдемо саме в логін, якщо
ми, наприклад, напишемо там щось рандомне.
Зараз треба перезапустити типу там щось таке.
Ось, користувача не знайдено.
Але якщо ми напишемо вірні дані.
Ухід успішний, тому що воно знайшло з цього
користувача.
Ну якась така простенька реалізація, тому...
Але це було б цікаво.
Так, ну тобто все воно працює, все цей.
Зараз нам просто треба...
Це воно вийшло тепер.
Наприклад, ось воно знайшло юзера, але невірний пароль,
тому написало невірний пароль.
Тому що знайдено юзера, але невірний пароль був.
Якщо ми перепишемо, то воно зайде.
Ось вхід успішний.
Це цікаво, я просто ніколи не працював з
базою даних, тому для мене це було таке
відкриття цікаве.
Прикольно всім було працювати просто.
Так, MongoDB досить проста в цьому випадку.
Відносно легко, у порівнянні з іншими, налаштувати і
використовувати.
Ну ось це, що стосується бази даних і
серверної частини.
Віталій, ти тут?
Так, я тут.
Можеш продемонструвати зараз, що в нас там ще
буде?
Так ось, на рахунок того, що реєстрація, я
трошки переробив, ось зробив менюшку таку.
Тільки не можу продемонструвати вам, чи воно працює,
тому що серверної частини на Станіславі.
Я розумію.
Зробив таку менюшку, потім зробив ще сторінку профілю,
спитав у Станіславу, чи зможе він реалізувати так,
щоб воно працювало з базою.
Він сказав, що спробує.
Тобто тут працює, ось наприклад.
Десь тут була пнг-шка, ось.
Воно працює.
Далі немає в інтерфейсі.
Спробуємо зробити так, щоб воно в базу зберігалось
якось.
Хоча б щоб ім'я, ну так, текстовий
профіль зберігався.
Так, це, мабуть, по цим загалом досить просто.
Ну, схоже до логі.
Поки що новин немає, я над ними зараз
працюю.
Це поки що просто картинки.
З кнопок у нас працює монстропедія.
Тобто у нас є готовий варіант ось такий.
Коротенький, але він готовий.
Далі у нас йде кнопка працевлаштування.
Тобто її ще, станіславо, треба буде додати до
бази якось.
Чи щось з нею зробити, щоб вона працювала
теж, десь зберігалась.
Далі у нас є товари.
Ось такі от.
Над ними я теж ще працюю.
Тобто, щоб кнопка купити працювала, там відкривалась сторінка
саме товару.
Я думаю, що я встигну зробити там небагато.
Потім йде події.
У нас йде робочий календар, але він просто
показує дату.
Ну такий календар, який працює, але просто показує
дату.
Ніяких відміток ось, наприклад, 13 травня бачити немає.
Далі що у нас, зв'язок.
Просто контакти.
Ну і на даному етапі все.
То я зараз працюю над тим, щоб новини
відображались.
Не знаю, чи встигну.
Ми обговорюємо додачу нових новин.
Тобто, щоб користувач їх додавав.
Навряд чи ми встигнемо це реалізувати, але поки
що таке у нас є.
Ну дивіться, виявляється досить дуже добре.
Це цілком як повноцінний сайт.
Я думаю, що ви можете попрацювати, закінчивши те,
що у вас зараз.
Тобто не додавати вже новий функціонал, а зробити
по-максимуму, щоб те, що існує зараз, працювало
добре.
Я думаю, що таким.
І також не забувайте, що вам треба це
буде закинути.
Ну, фронтен частину HTML закинуть десь на GitHub.
І там GitHub pages зробити.
І backend частину на рендер.
Ну, щоб інші також могли доєднатися, відкрити сайт.
Але там проблем взагалі не має бути.
Добре, можна ще питання?
Я зараз все почую демонстрацією.
Так.
Дивіться.
Ось зараз не той відкрив.
Оце влаштування.
Що зробити з цією анкетою?
Якби її просто в базу даних зберігати, це
дуже якось неправильно, можливо.
Як це можна було б щось з неї
зробити?
Куди її можна зберігати?
Вам би тільки в базу даних.
Фактично ви могли б просто скласти з цього
об'єкт зі всіма тими значеннями, тому що
я б бачив, що у вас, наприклад, четвертий,
п'ятий, вони багато можна варіантів вибору.
Тобто це дуже просто зберігається в такій же
структурі, як масив базу даних.
Тобто ви можете просто взяти це все і…
І закрінувати в базу.
Так, в базу.
Я не впевнений, чи воно вам треба.
Ви можете загалом залишити це в такому вигляді.
Або ж…
Ну, простіше, мабуть, було б все ж таки,
що якщо будуть питання на презентації, то створити
якусь там просту точку доступу на Node.js,
на XpressJS, і загалом просто це все закинути
в базу даних.
І нічого з ним далі не робити.
Тобто просто, що ви можете сказати, що нот,
воно в нас вже є збережене.
А Віталій показував ще вам анкету, де вход
фотографії, інформацію про себе.
Як це можна було…
Совєт, який можете дати, як це зробити?
З файлами…
Там є специфічний тип.
Так, я, можливо, зараз знайду щось.
Загалом з файлами досить буде важко це робити.
Не впевнений, що вийде просто, хоча б з
бази даних, тому що там доведеться витратити часу
для того, щоб перенастувати.
Дивіться.
Перший варіант, який я вам запропонував.
Я все ж таки спробую пошукати якісь простіші
методи, які б я не міг сьогодні скинути,
як зробити це.
Варіант номер два, ви могли просто можливо зберігати
їх десь на html частині.
Тобто просто зберегти файл для того, щоб не
відправляти його на базу даних, а десь локально
його, скажімо, зберігати.
Хоча б, щоб воно на якийсь період працювало.
Тому що з базою даних буде досить проблематично.
Я все ж таки пошукаю.
Можливо я знайду якийсь найпростіший приклад, як це
можна використати.
Просто проблем буде відправити саме такий файл до
того, щоб ви його потім завантажили.
Завантажити базу даних не є проблемою.
Проблемою в більшості для вас буде його нормально
потім обробити і відправити, а потім ще й
отримати повторно і відтворити.
Тому я думаю, що як варіант ви могли
б зробити, щоб користувач міг обирати, не завантажувати
нову, а, скажімо, ви там будете пропонувати список
уже готових і користувач якийсь там обирає собі.
Ви можете зберігати якесь значення в базі даних
для типу картинки і відображати її потім в
фронтені.
Такий спосіб, я думаю, буде простіше.
У вас просто буде вже готовий набір картинок
без потреби користувача завантажувати.
Дякую за інформацію.
У вас тут фактично два дні лишається.
Тому я б сказав, що там буде найпростіший
варіант, щоб занадто його не оскладнювати.
Чи є ще якісь запитання?
Так, в мене є питання.
Підскажіть, нам треба буде цей проєкт якось захищати?
В плані ось доповідь, якась презентація?
Чи буде достатньо того, що хлопці покажуть, що
вони зробили і все?
Дивіться, я думаю, що гарно можна буде просто
відкрити, показати конкретну частину, як це виглядає сайт.
Тобто ви можете там знімати посилання на сайт.
І не потрібно презентацію робити, але просто розповісти,
що у нас там є ось анкета, у
нас там є, скажімо, сторінка реєстрації входу.
Тобто базово представити ваш проєкт, про що він
взагалі, і все зробимо.
Таку простеньку на декілька хвилин, я думаю, цілком.
Добре, дякую.
Чи ще є якісь запитання?
Там навіть, напевно, немає.
Добре, тоді дивіться, якщо у вас виникнуть якісь
проблеми, можете написати в Телеграмі, ми можемо зв
'язатись і вирішити проблему чи в тактовому режимі,
або через Zoom, до поки, до п'ятниці
хоча б.
В п'ятницю у нас, я бачу, що
буде заняття на 9.30, ну а там
будемо дивитись.
Я не думаю, що воно займе аж годину
20, тому що в нас два проєкти, тобто
це будуть три презентації, і взагалом все.
Тому я думаю, що це досить, мало б
небагато по часу зайняти.
Ну і так, і не забувайте його все
ж таки завантажити, щоб можна було відкрити.
Добре, якщо тоді питань немає, я зупиняю.